so we want to know what democrats in
congress make of this fox's hillary
vaughn
just spoke to several of them and she
joins us tonight hillary thanks for
coming on
thanks for having me tucker well we've
been talking to lawmakers on capitol
hill all day trying to
ask the question
if they support people protesting
outside supreme court justices homes
interrupting church or if they think
these protesters should be prosecuted
for breaking federal laws in place that
ban that behavior
bottom line you don't condemn it you
think that these protesters should
continue to be outside supreme court
justices homes and interrupt church
interrupted and protested all the time i
welcome it in many ways as long as it's
not you know violent rhetoric uh talking
about you know
physical harm and all those kind of
things i think it's just really
important to understand that that
happens uh we're in public service this
supreme court said back then protesters
should be able to get right in people's
faces now they are erecting barriers to
try to keep protesters as far away from
themselves as possible i think that's
fundamentally wrong do you think that
these protesters should be prosecuted
for breaking federal law
what is the federal law i'm sorry it's
u.s code 1507 it prevents picketing or
parading in or near a building housing a
court of the united states or in or near
a building or residents occupied or used
by such judge do you think they should
be prosecuted for breaking federal law
the supreme court itself
has heard this argument and they have
themselves said it is protected by the
first amendment
so tucker even though there are these
laws in place as you heard there
preventing protesters from going to
judges doorsteps trying to influence
their decision from interrupting church
services a lot of these democrats that
we talked to are not budging and not
backing away from supporting this law
breaking behavior tucker
lori vaughn thanks for doing that for us
i appreciate it thank you
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight